[Music]
hello everyone I'm Juan Williams along
with Kennedy Jesse Watters Dana Perino
and Gregory Gutfeld it's five o'clock in
New York City this is the five
figure I have indulged you with extra
time but I appreciate indulgences
wearing out I appreciate it
there is a question our adult is more
out with you a long time ago mr. Djamel
I got to tell you that I'm about to
gavel you down another test today on
Capitol Hill Democrats and Republicans
clashing during the second public
impeachment hearing this time over
testimony from the former ambassador to
the Ukraine Murray Ivanovich Republicans
zeroing in on if the witness had
first-hand knowledge of key events there
are a number of events you are
investigating to which I cannot bring
any first-hand knowledge were you
involved in the July 25th Trump
szalinski phone call or preparations for
the call no it was not were you involved
in the deliberations about the pause and
military sales to Ukraine no I was not
no I was not
did you ever talk to President Trump in
2019 no I have not
Mick Mulvaney no I have not thank you
ambassador
not exactly sure what the Ambassador is
doing here today and one of the biggest
moments coming when President Trump
tweeted an attack on the former
ambassador in the middle of the hearing
chairman Adams Schiffman read the tweet
take a look I'll review part of one of
his tweets everywhere Murray Ivanovich
when turned bad and now the president
real-time is attacking you what effect
do you think that has on other witnesses
willingness to come forward and expose
wrongdoing well it's very intimidating
Democrats accusing the president of
witness intimidation
here's Crump's response tampering is
when a guy like shifty shift does it let
us have lawyers tampering is one shift
doesn't let us have witnesses does it
let us speak I've been watching today
for the first time I started watching
and it's really sad by the way it's a
political process is not a legal process
so if I have somebody saying I'm allowed
to speak up Dana I was with you all day
we were watching this and I think Bret
Baier said he thought that tweet really
change
everything today do you think that's an
example of Trump being as we're own
worst enemy well I think it changed it
changed it was like the moment there was
the only interesting thing that really
happened today
exactly there's that many of the members
of Congress on the Republican side said
to they maybe wouldn't have tweeted that
didn't like it but I think that the
Democrats and Adam Schiff in particular
he initially read it because he wanted
to make a point he was trying to say oh
look now the president's trying to
intimidate you but she wouldn't have
even known about it had he not read it
to her and then I think everyone got a
little bit carried away thinking that
this was going to be oh my gosh this is
another impeachable offense I don't
think so
it probably didn't necessarily help but
I think that but that was at 10 o'clock
this morning then by 4:00 o'clock when
we finished our coverage I think it had
pretty much dissipated that was like a
pretty fast news cycle I don't think it
ended up being as big deal and she oh
she's gonna diplomat skill and a
diplomat that's gracyk she's just steady
as she goes she didn't really react too
much she basically I don't know if
people were tuned in we'll have to see
if they do but I I just didn't think it
was all that exciting a hearing I don't
think that anything she said was very
damaging to the president I don't think
that anything she said was very helpful
to the Democrats it was just like
telling her story over and over and over
again there was the point that Lee's
Elden made he's the congressman from New
York Republican who said she was never
asked about part of the conversation
between Trump and zalenski on July 25th
was President zolensky saying to
President Trump yeah I kind of glad that
she's no longer going to be the
ambassador because she had a very good
relationship with the previous president
and he had some concern that Jovanovic
wasn't going to be as supportive of him
as she'd been of the previous president
and nobody brings it up but that's not
the Democrats fault like the Republicans
they're saying why didn't she bring it
up well actually the Republicans had a
chance to ask her nobody did so but now
now her testimony's done and maybe she's
having a drink by now I hope I think you
said all right so so Jessie she said
though that when the president was the
earlier transcript was released and the
president was revealed to have been
talking to the president of the Ukraine
about her and said you know she's a bad
ambassador she's gonna go through some
things she said she did feel in fact
that she had been smeared oh poor baby
when Obama got into office he fired all
the ambassadors and replaced him at will
he can do whatever he wants all
presidents can under Obama ambassadors
were coming back in body bags
now everyone's upset because one got
fired
so what people get fired all the time it
doesn't make a difference
witness tampering really shift colluded
with the whistleblower that's witness
tampering bribing how about what Obama
sends pallets of cash to Iran more of a
bribe than this freezing Abe for a blink
of an eye that's a bribe tweeting is now
an impeachable offense that's witness
tampering let me go to court let me and
then you want to get him for obstruction
they're criminalizing everything let me
interrupt you and say look at this shot
this sound on tape and and then you can
add to your point Jesse okay some have
argued that a president has the ability
to nominate or remove any ambassador he
wants that they serve at the pleasure of
the president and that is true I have
always understood that I served at the
pleasure of the president what listen
they needed something to create momentum
after Wednesday because Wednesday was
not good Wednesday was dull only 13
million tuned in more than twice that
tuned in for the Royal Wedding coverage
you know and we're tuned in for
inauguration and combing and Michael
Cohen this was a little blip they're
gonna lose interest very fast especially
after today they needed a moment they
needed tears and he did some powerful
moment and they just didn't materialize
and the Dow just broke another record I
just think everyone's lost touch with
the American people on this and they
don't see it because they're so wrapped
up in what's happening in decent alright
so Greg I wanted to play another sock
for you and and see to see what your
reaction may be do I shall react how did
that make you feel terrible
honestly were you aware that President
Trump had specifically made reference to
you and that call
No what was your reaction to learning
that I was shocked absolutely shocked
and devastated frankly what do you mean
by devastating how this has affected you
personally and your family yeah it's
been a difficult time I mean I I'm a
private person I don't want to put all
that out there but it's been a very very
difficult time how is it affected your
family I really don't want to get into
that but thank you for asking
great yeah they really wanted her to cry
there and they didn't get it look she's
a nice lady she's had a long career
that's irrelevant okay that entire
hearing was a travesty it was an
irrelevant hearing because it was based
on emotions interpretations feelings and
reactions to feelings about being fired
a natural process that I know personally
about three times I've been fired three
times I never had a hearing and by the
way I defend the bosses in my three
times that I was fired I was a really
good employee but the reason why I was
fired new boss new boss comes in he
wants new people if he doesn't feel that
you're gonna be loyal he gets rid of you
that happened to me when I was at men's
health it happened to me it's tough and
maximin I get that the fact that they
did a hearing where they talk about
quote you know felt threatened or when
they talk about Trump attacks he she is
not immune to Donald Trump the way none
of us are none of us are immune right he
comes in he shakes the box she's just
somebody that got fired this is why this
process is dead because there is no
bipartisan support for this because we
all know that what happened is
completely legitimate which is why it's
so ugly and why people are mad at each
other because they know it's BS can I
briefly just say but in fact the Trump
administration had renewed her in March
and then you see things change and then
then in the firing and who cares oh I
thought your point was the new boss and
so we can fire if she's playing maroon 5
in the office you can fire so Kennedy so
let me look at this from the Trump point
of view so is she the deep state someone
who served the country for 30 years
comes across
as a very patriotic public servant
that's the deep state no I think she's a
career diplomat I think there are people
within the surveillance apparatus that
that you could categorize as being part
of the deep state I wouldn't say
necessarily her and I think Republicans
and Democrats did a good job not only of
showing that that she had a very
impressive decades-long record but also
that she wasn't fired she was reassigned
and she's still employed and she's
teaching at Georgetown I mean that's
pretty great because if you've been
fired and you lose your livelihood and
you don't have a paycheck the next week
that sucks and that's what a lot of
Americans can relate to but this is what
we're talking about you understand we're
talking about someone's feelings and and
I think I will probably be upset if my
contract was renewed and then a couple
weeks later I was relieved of duty on
the next plane out of course but is that
a foundation for impeaching the
president no there was some really weird
stuff that went on and this has it risen
to the level of impeachment wolf it has
that's what we should be focusing on and
frankly we're not should the president
be tweeting at her mid hearing no it
makes him look like a big dumb baby and
he makes her look like a victim and if
you just let it go this entire the last
two days of hearings and testimony would
have been a snooze fest and to Dana's
point the news cycle moves so quickly
that even the tweet is being forgotten
Dana one last thing before we go the
White House tried to preempt some of
this by releasing a transcript of the
first phone call early at the time of
the hearing was starting yeah but then
when that came out it looked like the
president didn't talk about corruption
well we only have a little bit time
we'll just explain so anytime there is a
call between world leaders then you
usually there's a readout and often
you'll go to the press office goes to
the National Security Council they get
the information what did they talk about
okay fine or you listen and you do it
yourself and there's just discrepancies
right the the National Security Council
statement that was released through the
White House press office said they
talked about corruption and territorial
integrity and the sovereignty and they
they didn't talk about any of that right
it's again that's not impeachable it's
just a thing that happened today all
right there